Good morning John; it's Monday.
I have to say, yesterday: fantastic day. I
just had a great day yesterday. It was the
first of May, and true to Jonathan Coulton's
song, it was a gorgeous day outside, though
I did not have any al fresco fornication,
nor did I witness any, thank goodness. Katherine
and I went and got breakfast downtown, we
ran into some friends who were filming a movie,
and I got to be in their movie. We went to
see Win Win, the new Paul Giamatti m- awesome,
really good movie. I read Clash of Kings on
my back porch, Osama bin Laden was killed
in a precision military strike, Katherine
and I played Mario Kart Wii...
Actually, we were playing Mario Kart Wii;
Katherine had to go to the bathroom, I pull
out my phone to check Twitter, and by the
time she got back I had my laptop on my lap,
and I was watching Obama's address, with the
Mario Kart music in the background.
Obama: [with Mario Kart menu music] The United
States has conducted an operation that killed
Osama bin Laden, the leader of al-Qaeda.
Hank: It was a surreal moment. And, I'm not
gonna lie, Katherine and I high-fived. And
then we, uh, raced in the 100cc Banana Cup;
I was Donkey Kong, she was Yoshi, and... she
won.
So there are all kinds of interesting discussions
that I'm sure people will be having over the
coming days. Like, for example, is it okay
to high-five your wife over the death of another
human being? But instead of that discussion,
since, y'know, this happened, like, mere hours
ago - it seems a little premature to talk
about all the implications - let's just talk
for a moment about what we actually know before
we launch into the, uh, spin cycle.
Number one, despite the fact that Jack Bauer
was a trending topic on Twitter last night,
the death of Osama bin Laden had nothing to
do with rogue agents or weird intelligence
activities or breaking international treaties
or torture, which is a really notoriously
bad information gathering technique. And there
weren't even any twenty-four hour deadlines;
it was a long, thought-out, months-long process.
They gathered information over a long period
of time, and they put all that information
together using some great deductive minds,
and they, they figured it out.
Number two, CIA operatives and the Navy SEALs
involved in the action attempted to take Osama
bin Laden alive but were not able to. It is
unclear, uh, when this will be made in to
a made-for-TV movie, but my guess is minimum
six months. Five people were killed in the
attack, four of them were al-Qaeda members,
one of them was a woman who was used as a
human shield by one of those al-Qaeda members,
which is horrible.
Ayman al-Zawahri remains the number-one guy
at al-Qaeda, and he's been sort of the chief
of operations guy for a long time, and he's
a jerk, but according to what I've read and
various leaked documents from the CIA, he
doesn't have the same charismatic following.
It might be hard for him to keep the loyalty
that- that Osama bin Laden was kind of holding
together at al-Qaeda, so this could be a pretty
good thing.
And lastly, Barack Obama ordered this assault
right before flying to Alabama to survey the
damage done by the tornadoes and talk to the
people there, and then during the attack itself
he called the president of Pakistan. He was
like "Hey, president of Pakistan, just wanted
you to know we found bin Laden; we're coming
to get him; we're either gonna take him captive
or we're gonna kill him. And, uh, sorry for
not asking permission, but yeah, we're just
gonna do this." And that is a phone call that
I cannot imagine Donald Trump making, so...
glad Barack Obama was in charge just then.
That's just me, though.
I apologize for not, y'know, waxing poetic
as John probably would have about the, you
know, emotions of our country, about the morality
of assassination, as we receive this, ah,
cold-served dish. As for how I feel personally,
my emotions are in a lot of different places
right now. So let's just say this, uh, the
fact that I know that I should not be happy
at the death of another human being, uh, that
doesn't change the fact that I am.
John, I'll see you on Wednesday.
End screen! Sorry, not a very light-hearted
video, that. But, y'know. I have to say one
thing here, in John's last video, uh, lots
of people asked a question and then got 125
or so thumbs up, that question did, and that
question was "When is Hank's first album coming
out?!" and... two or three years ago... people...
This is my second album, this is the shirt
that came out with it. It comes with a poster,
seventeen songs on it, and we also just reprinted
these shirts; they were originally in green,
and now they're in black. My next album will
hopefully be coming out in, uh, the month
after this one. What is that? Um, April, May,
June. In June. That's all! Okay, bye!